News is now broken that fired
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe who
was fired by Jeff Sessions for quote
lack of candor just last week was
actually involved in a federal criminal
investigation into whether Jeff Sessions
himself lacked candor when he testified
before Congress about contacts with
Russians during the Trump campaign
testimony during which we now know he
lied and straight-up was dishonest
starting with Al Franken and ultimately
with others ABC News is reporting this
this changes a lot in terms of our
broader understanding of what it means
to try to obstruct investigations and
it's now becoming sort of so sketchy so
insidious it's the opposite of
everything that our elected officials
should be standing for and I was sort of
having trouble this morning when reading
through all the articles about this
thinking of what's the best way to even
explain to the audience what's going on
so I'm gonna do the best I can sort of
going back a little bit Donald Trump
appointed Jeff Sessions to be attorney
general he was prior to that a campaign
surrogate during Trump's campaign as a
senator from Alabama Jeff Sessions
during the campaign we now know had
numerous contacts with Russians when he
became Attorney General he was asked
about contacts with Russians and he
denied having had contacts with Russians
turns out that that wasn't true he later
explained that he had misspoke in it
just wasn't he couldn't remember totally
non believable explanations in every way
he was caught lying multiple times about
contacts with Russia sessions ultimately
recused himself on all matters related
to Russia and then most recently fired
deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe from
the FBI the general understanding of
this is that it was to further obstruct
the Russia investigation of Robert
Muller one of the few reasons that
sessions gave for firing Andrew McCabe
was that McCabe remember the quote
lacked candor during testimony and at
the time it sort of sounded really
really weird
and we've now learned that in fact
sessions himself was being criminally
investigated in an investigation where
Andrew McCabe was involved for lacking
candor during testimony now immediately
there are people all over the internet
saying oh well it's obvious sessions
fired McCabe as political retribution
because he knew that McCabe had
investigated him apparently not
apparently not what we're being told so
far is that sessions didn't know about
the investigation that Andrew McCabe was
involved in in two sessions own lack of
candor now that may end up not being
true we may eventually find out that
despite sessions lawyers saying now
sessions didn't know about the
investigation when it was going on that
he did but as of right now the idea is
sessions didn't know that the
investigation was going on Jeff Sessions
lawyer also saying that that
investigation was closed without going
any further
so as horrible a person as I believe
Jeff sessions to be and as much as he's
had the audacity to straight-up lie to
lawmakers during testimony I actually do
think that sessions does have a
connection to reality in terms of
realizing that there's an entire group
of people here in the Trump
administration that is potentially in
really serious trouble and that he is
sort of reachable I guess is the word
I'm looking for and by reachable I mean
he's not going to act in as erratic away
as Donald Trump would like him to act
I believe that Jeff Sessions under the
right circumstances might even be
potentially turnable by robert muller i
could be wrong but my idea here is that
what we really need to be focusing on is
why did this leak now i don't think the
story here is oh sessions fired mccabe
to punish him for having investigated
sessions I believe for now that sessions
genuinely didn't know about that
investigation so then we have to ask who
leaked the fact that sessions had been
investigated my book by McCabe one year
after the investigation why now would
anyone leak this
if sessions didn't know about it then
what would be the point of leaking it
now who might benefit from it leaking
now if you want to fire jeff sessions
then maybe you want to put some
thing out there about Jeff Sessions
himself having been the subject of an
investigation so if we are to speculate
as to who leaked this ABC News citing a
source familiar with the circumstances
which basically we understand to mean
someone within the Trump Organization if
you want to create a pretext for firing
sessions which could then be used as a
subsequent pretext for firing Robert
Moeller this isn't a bad thing to leak
and we will see if we ultimately find
out who the source of this leak was we
will ultimately of course find out
whether Donald Trump ends up using this
as some kind of pretext to fire sessions
which by the way would be insane right
if you were glad as Trump was that
mccabe was fired for his lack of candor
and that it was a great day for America
and for the employees of the FBI you
wouldn't then use a not an investigation
authorized by McCabe on sessions to fire
sessions it would be totally incoherent
but we've seen Trump do incoherent
things before so that's what I'm going
to be watching most closely and of
course the eventual goal of this might
be to fire Robert Moeller we found out
that Trump's new lawyer
Trump's prior head rusha lawyer John
Dowd has resigned there's a new guy that
has come in who has a very very
different approach than Dowd and he
reportedly is pushing Trump to fire
Robert Muller we will see where this
shakes out but just every single day
major revelations related to this entire
revolving door of firings and
resignations and investigations send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
today's program is brought to you in
part by blinka so you read books I read
books and if you're at all like me you
probably don't have time in your
schedule to read all the books that you
want to read there is an entire world of
nonfiction books out there that could
really feed your knowledge and infla
intellect but the sad truth is that
you're only able to read or tiny
fraction of those books but what you
could still do is absorb the most
essential knowledge from the books that
you don't have time to read and that's
exactly where blinka scums in it's an
app
that takes nonfiction books pulls out
the most important points and insights
from the books and it puts them in a
condensed sort of packaged form which
you can either read or listen to in
about 15 minutes on your mobile device
or tablet and over 4 million people are
already using blink as' it made the
iTunes best apps of 2017 list and you
can choose from a selection that is huge
thousands of books all of which you'll
have access to as a blinka subscriber
and you can switch between text and
audio both online and offline get
personalized recommendations based on
the books you've already chosen blink
astiz free to try and membership after
that is only a few bucks a month but you
can get a 20% discount if you go to
blink accom slash Pakman and if you're
watching on youtube we are linking a
tube Linkous and our link in the video
description one more time that is blink
is comm /p a que ma n